let's do a little Deep dive behind the
scenes of firefly Lane obviously we know
the show was based on a book but how
close do they stick to it without saying
anything she grabbed Kate's arm pulled
her through the living room if you've
seen other shows based on books you
might be surprised to find out pretty
damn close everything was pink walls
cabinets curtains tile counters table a
significant portion of the dialogue is
verbatim to the book's narrative is that
your mom Kate asked uncertain of what to
say
she has cancer if you watch closely
you'll notice the little movements that
were narrated in the book as well Kate
glanced back at the door to the living
room
she doesn't care if you smoke